what's the dilla's roots dog baby check
me out on the boulet care podcast
bootleg cab show special guest gang [ __ ]
back in this [ __ ] ruchi yeah
what's the deal taco son is here
welcome my friend what's that name i'd
like to uh just give you some
appreciation for the fact that you've
brought a bong
a hundred percent of the times you've
come on the show
yeah i don't go nowhere without my bong
i promise you nowhere like i like that
because it you know when i was a little
kid my dad would only smoke out of a
bong
and i was like little and i always
thought it was called the bomb a bomb
and um i remember like telling my
friends at school when i was like in
kindergarten or first grade like yeah my
daddy smokes out of a bomb
and uh
some someone told the teacher that [ __ ]
uh
and then my
they they pulled my my parents into the
principal's office and uh
yeah it was over a bong
but yeah what what are you like
never on the backwoods never on the like
are you strictly a bong hitter what is
i'm gonna tell you to get down
so
what i do is i roll a swisher up okay i
wrote a swisher up and i take pizza i'm
switching and just put it in my bowl you
got the leaf there yeah that's nice weed
in there oh there's a weed in there okay
but yeah i just roll a swisher up take
pieces off and
put it in my bone i don't know like you
know like roaches yeah like roses type
so will you put a roach in the yeah i
just break a pizza off my blood and put
it in there type [ __ ] wow i was in uh
alabama
like tuskegee type [ __ ] out there like
[ __ ] around i was broke as a
[ __ ] trying to save money and we
i started smoking chocolate swishers out
there right
then i started running out of like money
to buy [ __ ] bro so i smoked roaches out
of a bomb
and got so accustomed to smoking roaches
out of a bomb
now i'm
that's just all this money and i still
do the same [ __ ] yeah
you ever like go into a studio session
and the ashtrays got a bunch of roaches
no i don't touch nobody else roaches i
don't touch nobody else you never know
nah
like i said i wrote me up a bun not
break it down and put it in there
why were you in tuskegee alabama
man all right i was um
opening up for a homecoming for boozy oh
yeah what year was this
20
uh like
14 15 i think so you were like
young yeah i was i was probably like
like 21 20.
so you were opening up for boozy in
alabama yeah for the homecoming
touchdown my uh my folks i went to child
richard he was
going to school out there and he brought
us out there because he was like on the
little uh i guess what's that [ __ ]
called
fresh fresh by the way that's fresh out
of prison boozy yeah that was i'm coming
home that was i'm crazy boo see that one
yeah so yeah he was on the committee
type [ __ ] and he got us like to open up
on so we're doing shows out there
like they parties out there
was it homies trapping out there you
told me it was a vibe bro it was like
one of the best experiences i've had
like getting
like three in the morning drunk and go
to the gas station you can get chicken
and mac and cheese and yeah it's great
south yeah
you know as a west coast guy i was
living in florida i was living in tampa
when boozy got out of prison
and i didn't fully grasp i i'd always
known like i guess i had like a better
grasp
more than most people on the west coast
i didn't really fully understand like
the hole that boozy has in certain parts
of this country yeah that was that's my
favorite rapper like wow you guys got a
record together but in terms of like you
seeing it in alabama did that kind of
where you like [ __ ] this is different
let me tell you what happened i was we
was the people that was supposed to go
up right before him right
so boosie was that's when booty was just
i'm boozy like he like i want to go on
stage early we didn't get to perform oh
[ __ ]
yeah so he was out there really for
nothing not like just hanging out got
did you get a flick with him at least
nothing he i listen he was walking like
when they told us to get off stage
boosie don't perform like we was walking
on stage actually and they like you know
kind of past each other on stage and i
said something to him i'm like man
they're not trying to listen to the
phone cause he said you're going on
early
i guess he's my favorite rapper
he just walked past me did you tell him
this story when you ended up working
with him he'll not because now i
understand
the game and i ain't gonna lie to you
like i can't tell you that
like if he was coming to get his back
and get on that's what he was doing you
feel me yeah and that's what i've been
on sometimes too
for me so i
i probably took it hard back then but
like
when i seen him i was just so happy it
was like a fourth like full circle type
[ __ ]
he's one of the few um
artists that
when you meet him just doesn't
disappoint your expectations right
that's what man that's crazy that's what
we were saying too like
he came in he brought the vibe and he
thugged it with us you know what i'm
saying and
he a real hood [ __ ] like hey and back
then though he was doing [ __ ] to where
he was going to clubs
he was performing like
two songs and then he'll perform set it
off because he knew they like
started fighting yeah
and he did that yeah you feel me and i
was like what bro when he first got out
of prison he was getting stupid money
what dude he was getting like 125 000
[Music]
yeah sometimes you will like meet people
we grew up loving and then they'll like
disappoint us you know yeah
or you'll be like oh this is obviously
who i was watching on music videos and
in the magazines when i was growing up
yeah and i think i was so understanding
too always like of [ __ ] like
rappers like artists like
how they are like you know what i'm
saying like adapting to like
lifestyles like that and i was like i
always wanted to be that person
you feel me like i had dreams of like
walking somewhere like and ignoring all
these people that love me like you know
what i'm saying like
i don't do it but like you feel me it's
happening sometimes you get your [ __ ]
off it's rapper [ __ ] yeah so yeah like i
said like when i seen them again i'm
like damn
[ __ ] all that other [ __ ] man
how's that how's everything going with
your pops beautiful you get to go see
him in tj often yeah i just recently
took my son out there to meet him
does your dad uh got any plugs in hong
kong
nope
nope but yeah
nah he ain't got no place out there i
just i heard it's a nice place i've
never been it's a beautiful place i
heard too i've never been either never
been but i just heard that it's like a
good they got good food and they got
cheap drinks there yes yeah drinks i'm
djing in san diego on saturday so i
might go check it out
i heard they got good tacos
and nachos and you know natural supreme
yeah um
what are you listen you got the new the
new project drop yeah uh you've been
super active man i feel like uh we just
talked
before this album came out you had
dropped something else yeah i dropped uh
like like four mixtapes yeah you've been
on your [ __ ] bro like um
is that like do you do that [ __ ] on
purpose because you know sometimes
i feel like artists they make the
mistake of doing the opposite of that
they'll drop they'll get a buzz and then
they overthink the next thing and then
people don't care anymore when they drop
new [ __ ] shout out to g rico mozzie
like
i'll be just
listening to them
and they know
you're in a position where you always
tell me drop g don't like you feel me
like the flood [ __ ] like i already like
was paying attention to g and listen to
g caught me all the time and be like
bro like he just called me three days
ago he like
i'm good
doing what it's supposed to do drop
again you feel what i'm saying
and you're in a position where you can
do that yeah i'm ready yeah shout out to
empire oh my god the empire
everybody
is this narrative out there that
ruchi could do whatever he want to do
with empire bro like i've been doing
interviews and they said yeah i heard
you could do whatever you want to do at
empire like
i just think that
when you sign to a label it's on you bro
either you hot or you [ __ ] not bro
yeah sometimes people sign
and then they stop working because they
think all right cool i signed now
they're gonna do all the work
and i got the music together it's like
nah when you sign you gotta turn up your
work ethic bro gas up bro
being a face bro that's all it's about
and that's all i've been doing yeah
that's crazy because the first record i
ever heard from you uh the homie salas
had played me the uh silas the lean like
a trollo remake mm-hmm
and i just i was just trying to catch
what was that like four years ago mm-hmm
that's when i was really trying to cater
to all my hispanic fans like
that's where it's at
type [ __ ] yeah that was uh is that even
like on dsps
i don't know like could i go and say hey
lean like totally on dsps how did they
oh yeah
great record did you ever talk to down
aka kilo yeah they what they was on they
was on something remember
he was cool though yeah down aka kilo
yeah that's crazy they like
it's crazy when i did it i'm like
i didn't really give a [ __ ] i'm just i'm
about to just put it out like you know
what i'm saying
when he hit me up i'm like oh damn it
was fast though like and i wasn't even
that hot at that moment right hit me up
pretty early give me a fast and i'm like
oh [ __ ] okay [ __ ] can getting out there
type [ __ ] have you noticed like now that
you're a lot bigger
you can't do certain things that you
maybe could do three or four years ago
when it comes to just letting [ __ ] fly
or samples or just features yeah yeah
hell yeah you got to value yourself
you feel me even with shows
like i don't want to do all these shows
and just be everywhere like you know i
want to make myself exclusive like you
know what i'm saying like
i want people to actually like
not being used to seeing a big ruchi
show all the time i ain't really didn't
know shows in l.a at all yeah i feel
like the roxy was the last nah like hell
no like probably
i think after that observatory the last
time i saw you was uh
i saw you at when you were at uh before
the pandemic at day in vegas
yeah in vegas and that was one of my
worst shows ever that was just a cool
moment because i want to say it was you
was it one take jay yeah
it was just a cool moment
it was really like a
yeah my boy capsule of like that was
like that i didn't even like that day i
didn't even go to sleep or not it was
like a worse show to me because i
couldn't even rap i was throw [ __ ] up
voice going now the first time i ever
took a [ __ ] euro
i took a euro it's like a xcp oh okay
okay i took it the night before and i
never went to sleep i ended up losing my
phone all type of crazy [ __ ]
i had to go on stage that next day was
it worth it
yeah it was fun yeah
i don't regret [ __ ] i've never done any
sort of ecstasy i had south side from
ecstasy and you've never done noise i've
only eaten
you everything
no what
weed and shrooms
i come from a family of hardcore drug
addicts man you're doing shrooms bro no
no shrooms is [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
from the earth that's medicine right
that's molly it's pure
try molly they say it's pure until you
end up [ __ ] on tmz because you
overdosed on a [ __ ] fentanyl laced
molly pill like yeah this is good
you got to get the tester right that's
why i stopped popping pills
because of that
were you like a pretty like were you
just like recreational with the pill
popping or was it i was popping pills
i'm talking about
serious
popping pills
perk sex and everything no no perk sex
so what was your pill of choice i have
tried them
uh actually
regular cpu so you're telling me to try
accessing you stopped yourself i stopped
it because like you said
but i feel like you should have tried it
yeah southside from 808 mafia offered me
one in the middle of our interview shout
out to uh
hey that's my boy too he's you know what
he told me what he told me you're gonna
send me a beat i almost lost my
[ __ ] mind but that's because he
[ __ ] with the homies from the other [ __ ]
he's the coolest [ __ ] like we
have the most hilarious
talk ever shout to bro for real shout
out to bro and like
he's like really really uh
he pop x
oh yeah that's what's up yo what up man
we got to stop the interview real quick
to tell you about our good folks at blue
chew that's right go to bluetooth.com
fellas
you know sometimes
you go through some stress you go
through a little anxiety and your dick
is not
performing maybe how you'd like it's
called ed a lot of guys go through ed
you could just be old as [ __ ] if you're
watching this and your dick ain't
working like it did when you were like
20. you know what i mean well listen
buchu
it is the wave uh how about this the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis getting delivered right to your
door in a chewable form in discrete
packaging and the best part about it is
it's all online zero awkward visits to
the doctor's office zero you go online
you sign up with the promo code bootleg
that's right bootleg when you check out
you will get the first month for free
all you gotta do is pay five dollars on
shipping and you're gonna get one
month's supply of blue chew all right
and you're gonna be [ __ ] like you
were [ __ ] never [ __ ] before your
dick's gonna
i'm gonna assume
you're adding at least a quarter of an
inch of erection that shit's gonna be
rocked up rocked up and socked up all
right boys so what you need to do one
more time go to bluetooth.com and use
that promo code bootleg and get your
first month for free
bootleg promo code bootleg on
bluechoo.com let's get back to the
interview yeah he does a lot that's why
i be saying like sometimes like if you
popped it you
like you get back in that mold sometimes
like
he was talking about how he one time
like uh he would he's done ecstasy
thinking he was gonna [ __ ] a [ __ ] that
night
well listen and then didn't and then
ended up jacking off into the [ __ ]
sun came he said it was a longer jerk
not quite a better jerk but a longer
jerk nah [ __ ] jacking off multiple
times when you don't get no [ __ ] like
have you ever jerked off on ecstasy what
[ __ ] it'd be nice like when you really
think you'll get some or [ __ ] just you
just take a pill yeah and you really end
up in that bed by yourself it's all over
man have you ever taken like a honey
pack or a rhino thinking
that she made my hair hurt the next day
yeah did they do that for sure nah
ryan i took a rhino when i was young
yeah 18.
i just did it because just cause why not
they're at the gas station right this
should be good yeah and i did it that
she was crazy did you did you
do it and then
hook up with a chick did you feel like
[ __ ] yeah a different thing yeah you
know what i'm saying but it's just like
performance enhancing it's like uh when
barry bonds started doing the roids like
he was already a good baseball player my
dick to go down to like [ __ ] eight in
the morning
the worst part is is the weight you wake
up with the hardest erection ever [ __ ]
can't even pee in a toilet shooting
bro there's have you ever have you ever
you got a stance yeah you gotta you
gotta stand over the toilet bro that's
real
the
the piss boner baby bash would call it
the piss boner man bro yo shout out to
baby bash baby bash should always tell
me stories about how you'd wake up in
the morning and [ __ ] chick with his
piss boner
baby bad
damn hey see i knew all these [ __ ] be
living this crazy ass lifestyle bro baby
bad sugar sugar baby badger yeah that's
my guy babe that's a wild boy that's
pharaoh he's got he's got some of the
wildest um
we gotta have baby bash on the podcast
[ __ ] i'll be he's got like wild stories
oh my god
just especially with like
the biggest porn stars ever the [ __ ]
he's done it's like it's crazy shout out
to bash good guy
do you feel like um
you said when you first came out you
were trying to like really
focus and hone in on the latin crowd
do you feel like
it's possible to do both
yep
[Music]
all right something like this
i go to a shoreline show i pop out at
shoreline show right
they go crazy his fans go crazy you feel
me that's all that's that's trying to
show i pop out of the katelyn show they
go crazy all the black people go crazy
you feel what i'm saying well you're
kind of the first artist to really be
able to do that right yeah so i'm trying
to i'm really trying to master them but
i feel like i got it but i got to master
it bro
i got to give my
my fans something to really love about
me type [ __ ]
would you be down to do like the
lowrider shows and [ __ ] like that yeah
hell yeah yeah those are fun i don't
like that's what i said i don't be like
i'm open to a lot of [ __ ] bro yeah
what about uh mexican artists is there
any mexican artists that you
that you're fans of
dropped jlp you know what that is name
hey jesus uh i've got his last name
there's this dude from uh houston that's
called like
[ __ ] what's that dude's name from
houston
my my grandma want me to work with the
biggest though who i sent you oh and
[ __ ] like that oh remember
me to work with bad baby and stuff like
that bad baby is a female who had plenty
bad bunny 20 million dollars on only
fans bad bad buddy is who you mean she
made a lot of money on only fans god
that tells you what kind of creepy
[ __ ] is out here bro
like if you spent money to subscribe to
a 17 year olds only fans account that's
crazy you're [ __ ] a sick [ __ ] shout
out to her though shout out to her run
it up
and her music
wasn't as bad as i never heard her music
it wasn't terrible i didn't even know
she had music she had a song with kodak
black that was solid oh god yeah
well listen to that i mean it wasn't
great but it wasn't like
i thought with kodak though so it's
better than like a little pump song for
sure you know
i don't even listen a little pumped up i
mean who does anymore
it's 20 22.
it's been a while since it's been a
while since eddie was listening to a
little pup song yeah nice nice kid
though you know shout out to him uh what
do you listen to though like if i were
to get in your car we're driving on a
[ __ ] road trip what am i hearing in
the car man
be honest bone thugs [ __ ]
kodak
um
hot boys i'm real like like like hot
boys like lil wayne bg
um
boozy
what about uh so bone thugs
what is your go-to bone thugs project
he's 19.99 that's the one or creep it
for me it's creeping on creeping on the
coming part too but i think he's 99 like
i just
even at that intro bro yeah creeping on
a come up just changed my life as a kid
so i have like um there's two albums
that
i have that feeling with it's dad and
doggy style
so creeping on a come up for me will
just always forever be like a moment in
my life where like things change for me
or neptune i played a lot of neptune of
course i think that the marathon changed
my life
i could see that i was you know i was in
high school at that point i had dropped
out and everything and
it was i was listening to nipsey i was
were you scared uh well i mean i first
discovered bone when i was like six so
all the ouija [ __ ] i thought that [ __ ]
was real yeah um so [ __ ] had me spooked
low-key my mom wouldn't like that [ __ ]
right what i'm saying like she but i
didn't like he's crazy because i didn't
even i was so much of a fan of them like
that [ __ ] was nothing to me like oh i
love bone bro it was all the bone solo
[ __ ] i had i had [ __ ] when crazy bone
dropped thug mentality when busy bone
drop uh
burner and all that alberta
and then shake out harry because
then they like
really
everyone kind of
went their separate ways for a while and
you could tell they all kind of needed
money and then like
busy bones started dropping like full
projects with high power records and
uh
it did it [ __ ] got hairy with the boat
[ __ ] for a while there for sure um but
shout out to bone shout out to bondage
you know who else used to freak me out
uh did you ever listen to brother lynch
hung yeah
season of sickness the thing about him
too he had joe like
he wanted who had my mind thinking
different like you know what i'm saying
like i didn't listen to a lot of them
but when i did him was like damn bro he
had an album called season of the
sickness and i used to listen to that
[ __ ] i used to borrow my friend ramsay
says cd
it was a tape maybe and
he's talking about eating babies
oh yeah guess what daddy's bringing home
for supper nuts and guts and slabs of
human meat [ __ ] now eat nah i
was like bruh
and i believed that [ __ ] but this [ __ ]
was so hard
you got me off these little [ __ ]
shrooms and she talked about eating
babies bro that's what brother lynch was
known for he was like kind of like a
pioneer in what they used to call horror
core rap you don't even know how i just
imagined like a baby right here but as
well he talked about feeding his baby
human human feet like about next subject
the sickness shout out to you bro yeah
sacramento legend sacramento ladies and
gentlemen crazy crazy guy for sure for
sure man um
what about like on just like uh
are you do you have any aspirations to
like sign artists yeah be an executive
um
i'm gonna start my uh
on record label called doggy bone
records i love it yeah and
i don't want to um deal with no like
rappers though
i mean if i'm not saying like
i would never sign a rapper or anything
like that but
i want to do something different bro i
i'm in love with like
90s r b
the groups
[ __ ] like that yeah there's no more r b
groups i always say this like what
happened to the r b group lost art form
no more 112s no more jagged edges yeah
or even like that and like escaping
all that [ __ ] is like so yeah i want to
do something like that or i want to do
some country [ __ ] too
do you like country yeah
nice [ __ ] with it what's your go-to like
who do you like what's your country [ __ ]
i think like the cliche [ __ ] i just love
tim mcgraw how he was like was and then
um i got a
friend named willie jones too from
empire yeah yeah
like i just be like clinging on like to
random like country [ __ ] too
yeah you uh
tim mcgraw
had a song that was uh
lived like i was dying yeah you know
that song
i
it's like such a beautifully written
song i was like how about that like i
can't even explain like how that song is
it's like him essentially singing
from the perspective of someone who just
found out that they have like stage four
cancer
and like how he'd live like he was dying
yeah this [ __ ] i don't know why on my
tv every time like i like turn off like
hulu or something it goes to this
[ __ ]
um
this [ __ ] tv show called like
it's like a hillbilly like network type
[ __ ] right
and they there's country singers on
there all day bro and how do you watch
it
yeah i don't even know these people be
bro and i just be listening to it like
i am i mean i uh shazam the song and
[ __ ] like they do say country is just
the rednecks rap taking a melodies and
[ __ ] like that like hey man there's some
fire country there's some fire [ __ ] and
like loki like if you listen to like the
verses
they're low-key just rapping
they're really just talking their [ __ ]
in their but in their [ __ ] over their
music and
johnny uh cat uh
johnny johnny cash was like
he was talking some gangster [ __ ] waylon
jennings was talking some gangster [ __ ]
like they were talking about waylon
jennings was talking about killing and
they didn't have no like filter neither
at all like they got to talk about
whatever they want right oh god but yeah
i want to sign some crazy [ __ ] i don't
want to do no regular [ __ ]
i can see you that'd be crazy if you
found a la country artist yeah i want to
do just i want bro i want to write music
i want to
put like produce music i want to do all
that [ __ ]
are you making beats
no hell no
i'll be having too much going on right
now but
if i if i start making beats i'm going
to be the best producer in l.a and i
don't want to [ __ ] [ __ ] over like that
have you
like [ __ ] around with it at all
i sit there and like with all my
producers and make all my beasts you but
i'm saying you're pretty hands-on with
the process hell yeah yeah i don't even
like people sending me bees do you ever
have an idea for like a sample and then
send it to your guys like yo we got to
sample this every day
nice every day
have you ever gotten to the point where
you have a record that you love
but the to clear the samples way too
much and you're like [ __ ] we can't drop
it no we empire
empire got it we're good
well they say you could do anything you
want over yeah we're good
talk to me about the empire [ __ ] because
i i do think like um
it is a very unique situation
and i feel like you're one of the
artists who's done a great job of
navigating empire
to your advantage
because i see some people like we talked
about earlier like uh g parikho like he
got on empire left rock nation went to
empire and turned the [ __ ] up you know
what i'm saying but i feel like you've
been turning the [ __ ] up really the
whole time yeah um they give you a lot
of resources bro
like they open that studio up for you
and let you be in there and let you
really get your issue off yeah you just
go hang out in the bay for a week and
just yeah it's time to sundown you feel
me um
guys and nema tap in like a [ __ ]
they make you feel appreciated you know
what i'm saying shout out to gentry
shout out to gentry bro um
he just makes sure like
i'm getting what
the [ __ ] is getting over there you
know what i'm saying like as far as the
looks
um the [ __ ] marketing find what you
just
gentry be real hands-on like with
holiday and tuck and they all make sure
like
that i'm on the same path
type [ __ ]
um any uh more joint projects
um
well producers probably well producers
where you just do a whole project
yeah i do i'm not doing probably i ain't
doing no more projects to nobody
how'd the trek thing go it was move it
was smooth i think um
if we like we had some big ass records
on there too yeah for sure uh if we
probably record was on there right yeah
and by the way the um
the artwork was [ __ ] crazy yeah
outside [ __ ] he tried to try for that
but if we would have put more uh
probably turned up the promotion more
and like had it on that end we probably
would have did better than
it did but
it was like i said it was like a good
ass like
experience for sure
yeah a lot of that [ __ ] yeah no i think
people love that project and i think
like uh there was
a lot i feel like you guys got a lot of
love for that project hell yeah yeah
it gave us another platform for sure
yeah and at that time like
yeah i thought i thought that [ __ ] did i
mean [ __ ] man i knew a lot of people
there talking about that album
um
for you man like uh
being out of inglewood
coming from the family you come from
what do you kind of want
your legacy to be in like 20 years when
we think aruchi when we think of
you know the city when we think of just
ruchi overall the greatest ever to come
out of inglewood
um changing would uh give back to the
community like a [ __ ] always
around
i just want to be known and loved by my
city like nipsey um
do you have any plans of like
getting some real estate opening some
businesses hell yeah
it's getting there yeah that's why i'm
dropping so much shout out to 211's got
his story i know he's got a new story
shout out to the level up story if you
need some fly [ __ ] go to level up i
don't do this so i need to do this some
more often
level 11
follow to 11 instagram follow the level
up store go up there
got everything and he's got a new one
coming at so far
yo it's kind of wild like what is your
thoughts on the whole sofa i think that
[ __ ] gangsta
first of all it's an amazing stadium
it's crazy because like you're you're
driving like
you know
through inglewood and it's almost like a
switch gets hit and it feels like you're
in like a different place
actually gangsta bro i think like
i i think like they asked me about this
[ __ ] like three years ago even the
police used to ask me like what you
gonna do in the stadium come like [ __ ]
i'm gonna be rich with them people [ __ ]
i'm about to give me a house over there
what the [ __ ]
type [ __ ] like it's just
that [ __ ] just like putting another
light on us bro like well i think with
me like because i'm from inglewood you
know
i like i i
hopefully one day i can perform at a
[ __ ] halftime show you know what i'm
saying like
i just i just it just opened more doors
i'm sure the rams would have you hell
yeah
i'm gonna get it together i gotta give
they'll give you a jersey i'm gonna get
my rams on listen they gave the homie
jason castro jersey and he's not from
englewood you know me and he's not a
rams fan but json can't put no for l.a
so you know what i'm saying
i saw him at the uh rebs cardinals game
and i said ain't you a [ __ ] raiders
fan bro
you ain't turning down the opportunity
you ain't going to turn down the freaks
fan oh you're a saints fan yeah
[ __ ] that's random as [ __ ]
because of reggie though reggie bush
yeah now reggie got drafted uh the
saints i was a big reggie they got the
ring
they got the ring hurricane katrina all
that like now the saints were fired i
was just champagne drew brees reggie
bush yeah it was just like a thing
and then when they had jimmy graham
mm-hmm
and then jimmy graham left and then i
don't know what the [ __ ] happened
and then it was like it was still
something i'm going through but i think
like even
with thomas getting hurt i know thomas
is always hurt but we feel like a.k.a he
cold bro
i feel like he signed the cash money or
something he signed the qc qc that's
what i meant yeah yeah he's always got
the chain on it he's got the sports
agency yeah i was gonna say like
yeah i don't know that's fire though
yeah it's super fire
do you know what happened uh ricky
williams uh who got drafted by the
saints back in the day wasn't he signed
to no limit or something yeah but i
guess he signed to no limit
and got like the worst like contract in
like nfl history what
he
he missed out on like a bunch of money
because he didn't sign a uh a guaranteed
deal
he did like a fully incentive based deal
and got injured and then and he had so
many endorsements around that time i
remember that [ __ ] bro and now he starts
smoking weeds now he's got the goddamn
weed strained mm-hmm but that's crazy
how the life changed
like
bro he was the goat too you see montrez
harold just got caught in the middle of
kentucky in a 2020 honda pilot with five
pounds of weed what
yes yesterday mantra is harold you
remember he was on the clippers in the
lakers
you gotta figure it out
i to know why is he in a honda pilot in
kentucky did he trying to figure it out
bro he's a millionaire
he got the bag
obviously he feels like he ain't got
enough he's trying to do it up five
pounds of weed like you got you got a
driver
did he go down
yeah he's just facing felony charges for
uh you stealing yeah he got arrested
yesterday free bro
free bro
if you got i mean if you get pulled over
with five pounds of weed in la i feel
like it's probably not as bad as this
they will but it's not kentucky you know
at least thursday are they trying to
figure out why the [ __ ] you like five
pounds a week like you know what i'm
saying they thirsty as [ __ ]
what do you think about cause you know
la's kind of nationally getting a bad
rap right now obviously the homeless
shit's happening but
every every week we see a new video
someone getting robbed on melrose or
you know
wherever people there's a lot of [ __ ] i
mean you saw at fox hills mall they uh
they just did that snatch at the the
smash and grab yesterday
that's why i feel like the gun laws is
[ __ ] out here because it's like
well we got to protect ourselves like
you feel me like even like walking
around with this much jewelry on and
[ __ ] like this like
it's almost like you'll risk the
whatever consequences that come with
having a gun illegally so yeah because
you'd rather have it then i got friends
i got i literally got friends like you
know wealthy friends right
who won't even just they don't they
don't even go outside with no jerry on
they go outside on some real regular
[ __ ] nowadays just because of that type
of [ __ ] you feel me
like
but it's it's that lay bro like
our [ __ ] don't stop our [ __ ] ain't
gonna never stop bro like what do you
think it was cause cause do you because
edd was bigger here probably than
anywhere else yeah so all that [ __ ] left
yeah you feel what i'm saying and they
see who still got it left mm-hmm
and they gonna leave them with nothing
because once you get that that edd bread
was crazy
that was the beauty of 2020 that was a
moment
there's gonna be a documentary on
netflix in like five years ago i'll drop
my own
dude
what
i'm like bro
that would that was like like some
like some unreal [ __ ] like i've i've
seen people with money who never had
i've seen people who never had
five thousand dollars they jumped from a
twenty dollar bill to twenty thousand
dollars i saw people who didn't own a
car
end up with a rolex and a [ __ ]
hey we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our good folks
at odd socks listen the most comfortable
socks in the entire world i promise you
are these odd socks basics right here
now i like the uh the
high joints the whites or the blacks
we're very inclusive at the bootleg kit
podcast love the blacks and the whites
of odd socks of course um but they also
got the crazy licenses they got ninja
turtles they got a [ __ ] scarface
breaking bad socks which i just
rewatched amazing and their underwear
the best man i was just talking to
somebody about how fire the odd socks
draws are because the waistband it don't
fold they're just comfy as hell so go to
odd socks
official.com you see the website spell
it that same way and use the promo code
bootleg cab all one word together and
you'll get 20
off from our presenting sponsors our
family at odd socks it's all that's on
my ass and feet ladies and gentlemen so
we'll get you some odd socks let's get
back to the interview brand new how many
cars i rented during that [ __ ]
i was probably spending like down there
forty sixty thousand dollars on running
cars just running renting just because i
don't have no license nobody wants me to
drive i'm not the driver you don't want
roots to drive at all that's how i am i
drive with two feet that's all right
yeah so and i was just raising cars
i was like that for a while where i
would just uh i didn't have a car for a
while and i would just rent a car for a
month and just pay like whatever
yeah i need to give me like a black
truck or something
just get a lease and then you could
write off a big part of the lease
because uh just connect it to your llc
or to your music something i can't drive
i don't know you don't have a license
never had a license to go get one
my stepdad when i was like growing up he
was always like let me just
just whip
yeah so i gotta get your license man
you're a grown-up i never bro
i just that [ __ ] nothing is driving me
to get my license
it's probably a shitty dmv line
you could probably set that up i can't
sit in the front you got to get your
[ __ ] lights i gotta go somewhere far
now dave to go to a [ __ ] dmv look at
the d go get your license and bomb deal
or something
they know me and palmdale bro i can't be
in palmdale like that yeah go the
[ __ ] hammock
hey man
temecula they know me in temecula but
temecula's nice
you're right it's a lot of old people
out there who love wine all right i'ma
figure it out bro but i could see they
probably feel like i drive with two feet
i don't think they don't matter
like all grown-ups need their driver's
license i got my id [ __ ] i just got
my id
you just got an id so what were you
doing before that pulling out your birth
certificate no
just
telling them how the [ __ ] were you going
across the border to see your pops oh i
had
like that was like you know what i'm
saying i had a birth certificate but
even that [ __ ] was i would get double
checked yeah passport nope oh yeah man
yeah you know it's crazy [ __ ] i i had a
pat i mean
first they gave me when i had got id
right they put that my birthday was in
like 1999 or some weird [ __ ]
i just send back my id
so when i got a passport the last time
they put that my birthday was in 99
again
so i had to send that [ __ ] back and i
still ain't got your passport yeah yeah
good luck that [ __ ] takes forever yeah
bro you know what's so crazy i think
it's somebody else with the same name as
me and a birthday in 99.
because they keep waiting
94. okay good year
young man you're the doggy style you're
the dog
yeah you everyone else yeah and uh
shout out to snoop dogg shout out to the
artwork very
very reminiscent to the doggy style dog
father you know arab snoop yeah that's
all from that bro awful snoop bro
straight up that's crazy
everybody like
don't understand like
like even like the whole dog [ __ ] how he
carried that [ __ ] like
he made people like dogs like
just dogs do you think people didn't
like dogs
i don't know bro they feel like they've
always been adored
homeward bound
and [ __ ]
101 dalmatians yeah but not no [ __ ]
dobermans and pit bulls and [ __ ] like
that probably probably the pit bull
doberman thing yeah
because when snoop dogg was a doberman
and they turned into snoop yeah he made
to like the hood dogs looked tight like
yeah same people was in the kitten you
have dogs
i've had dogs all my life um i just had
a dog i moved to a new apartment
can take the dog he was there for a
little bit but he can
it's really my little brother dog and
we'd be on the go so much we had to just
give them to our cousin type [ __ ] yeah
you gotta talk like a kid man
you really don't know that until you get
one though you know there's a lot of
these rappers running around out here
with these [ __ ] exotic frenchies and
they treat them like [ __ ] accessories
they're not like animals yeah so i don't
even i don't even like i probably when i
get older for sure gonna get some dogs
again but like yeah once you get the
crib maybe yeah my house growing up i
had like for sure i had a kennel in my
backyard if you go look at my old videos
my step-ups built a kennel in my
backyard we had
like four different four or five
different dogs like a bull mastiff it's
a big dog um
we had like actually three bull massive
but two of them were mixed with the pit
and we had a pit and a rottweiler [ __ ]
which was the in-house like the house
dog be inside yeah no one's coming to
your house to [ __ ] around yeah so if we
but i used to get like go outside and i
used to go through it with dogs bro like
my dog robbie like to get outside and
they all jumped the throttle like i'm
talking about
eating at him like he feel me the inside
dog would get beat up by the outside
dogs yeah bro and they were jealous bro
and one time i stuck my hand in that
[ __ ] bro you bit
the rottweiler bit me he didn't bite
them he bit me and my [ __ ] start
blushing good everywhere like [ __ ]
bro that [ __ ] a headache bro and it was
a lot of dogs bro
i don't know how my stepdad still keep
up with him now
i just have two tiny dogs yeah i have a
pomeranian and a frenchie
they're small they're [ __ ]
you know they're just they're like i
mean they're gay
i think when i'm i've like the dogs of a
gay man
like my dogs aren't actually
my dogs aren't actually gay but i feel
like they're like if i was uh if someone
saw me walking my two dogs they'd
probably be like yo boo like kevz this
is is he uh playing on the other side
yeah i got a [ __ ] furry little
[ __ ] pomeranian [ __ ] dog bro like
but see like i think when i was like
because i'm like i said i'll be on the
go bro like i got an apartment but i
don't i didn't get it like really i just
i need somewhere to stay you feel me
would you ever live anywhere else but
besides l.a yeah hell yeah i really want
to go to the south
for sure go to go to [ __ ] houston or
houston houston is amazing
oh great strip clubs
and the mexican food's still good mm-hmm
food out there to me the food's amazing
and it's a great city good i mean
bad abortion loss good gun laws though
but i want to like when i get it
together and give me a little get a
house in vegas like
i was going to say vegas is the move you
know what's so crazy though hey z
mansions
i don't know a lot of the states that's
[ __ ] with az mansions bro or az women
listen that's a whole nother story
that's like i promise y'all i've never
like
been to hazy and not got no [ __ ] loki
good for you yeah i'm sure you've
probably uh [ __ ] women i know out
there
you ever been to jaguars
no oh
you haven't been there every time i know
but like that's what i'm saying i don't
be going places in children i'll be on
the go falling in the driver i'd be like
on tour or something like and you feel
me or i got to do a show out there and
i'm there for a night and a half like
you feel me
that's it tell me but like i said i'm
getting older bro like so i'm really you
know a lot of people are um start taking
my time getting cribs in vegas because
there's no state tax
[ __ ] out there it's cheap and you don't
have to pay no taxes that's hard as a
[ __ ] because in cali the uh
estate tax is pretty serious man that
weather you know
bro why is it so hot in [ __ ] palm
desert
it's hot
[ __ ] we just went to el centro two
nights ago it was you were in el centro
oh [ __ ]
random as [ __ ] huh mc magic has an
artist named jay rocks that he signed
that's from el centro shout out to her
nice lady but yeah el centro it's like
an air force town right well i don't
know where they got the [ __ ] air
force base there by the border too it's
like uh it's on your way from if you
were to drive from san diego to phoenix
you hit el centro right by mexicali buy
mexicali yeah but like i said
like hot i didn't have a look i didn't
even have a lot of like people there
like it was a good show but it wasn't
like sold out or nothing right
but to see the [ __ ] that's from
el centro that liked me it was like
what the [ __ ] like i don't have nobody
out here to like like
central's uh in the middle of nowhere
it's like blife
bliss damn you know what's crazy is when
i was like really heavy into like
selling drugs
belith was
i used to pick up work in blyth
obviously marijuana not talking about
anything crazy but like
life is a little it's very like a
population is small my uh one of my high
school teachers
uh grew up in blacks and she used to
always just tell us like
every time i'm so
happy to be here because
it's terrible it's like
i see the same 10 people every day i
stop at the same gas station to piss
every time i'm driving to phoenix
and the last two times i've pissed at
this gas station it's in the same
parking lot as the denny's
there's been a
crackhead smoking crack in the bathroom
in blight imagine being a crackhead and
bliss that's probably a hard place to to
be a crackhead it's [ __ ] 120 degrees
like a homeless crackhead in black smoke
and crack right like if i'm gonna be a
homeless crackhead i'm just i'm getting
to la somehow
i'ma go to portland if i was a homeless
crackhead i'm going to jail
portland might be nice i'm going to jail
can you get crack in jail though
figure it out you're already doing crack
you could do with some other [ __ ]
you get free re free rent in jail
i don't know man some of these homeless
[ __ ] is living nice in these
tents bruh
these tents are serious little
contraptions tell me about it bro
like i literally got family members like
bro like you don't want to staying in
the tents
i got a family member that told me some
crazy [ __ ] like i'm like
you don't know apartment or nothing he
said nah i got two cars
what
he's like yeah this 10 ain't [ __ ] like
so he lives in the tent but has two
cars why didn't you live in the car
you probably do that too wow yeah
there's a lot of downtown parks but
there's a lot of people who well there's
a lot of people who choose to be
homeless
no for real i had a little cousin like
that too like
he would choose like like when he was
growing up he would choose like to
like not go home and sleep in an alley
and i never got it nobody ever
understood it imagine like in the middle
of the pandemic you could go live
on the beach in venice
you'd go to venice beach
and live rent free on the beach
and they won't [ __ ] with you now they
did clean it up like in the last 90 days
it's gotten cleaned up but
for like a year and a half venice beach
i don't know if you went during that
pandemic i don't even think i win that's
crazy bro it was [ __ ]
venice beach was like skid row on the
water
it was wild
but imagine if you're a hump like i said
spyro what's the homeless crackhead in
blyth doing when you can go get free
beachfront properties
two hours up the [ __ ] freeway man
yeah i feel that like i'm going to
venice beach to be homeless [ __ ] blythe
bruh
crap that's the same price [ __ ] being
homeless bro
not for sure for sure i [ __ ] crack
crack's not probably the crack is wack
it's probably not the drug to
participate in even though i i do have
my uh who said that crack is whack uh
sounds like some 90 [ __ ] it was like a
no it was like a
commercial no
like wanted to like look like the first
lady who was
who was the first lady at that time it
was like it was nancy reagan yeah she
said crack is whack on like on there on
drug [ __ ] in the press conference
[ __ ] the war on drugs
they've been losing that [ __ ] for 30
years
you watch uh snowfall like a
[ __ ] great show yeah i love it
yeah great show i had freeway rick ross
up here he's a talker the real one the
real
i mean not the fake one the real
do you know if there's a fake freeway
recross running around doing interviews
no i just had the real one cause he
always say the real one i'm the real one
yeah he's gotta like let that let the
whole rick ross thing go man yeah
there's more money to get he should be
he's he should've had rose bro he should
have got out of jail and been like yo
man i love how you're keeping my name
alive
let me narrate an album people don't
think like that bro people want
everything
every day
everything
because rosa living
do you see his house
who didn't
you see that he got that house and then
he rented it they um
the movie the coming to america sequel
that was on prime i think i've seen that
[ __ ] they rented his house over for like
one and a half million dollars to shoot
the [ __ ] and he paid like
i don't know what he paid for that house
but if it was close to one of that it
was like whatever they paid him to rent
the crib was close to what he paid for
the house which really now that i'm
thinking about it and i'm on shrooms
it's got me thinking how much i just
paid for my house in burbank
and my stomach hurts now
because his house in atlanta is like a
so you got a house in burbank yeah i
just bought a house in burbank
congratulations bro that's that's big by
now in l.a
yeah it was expensive man
definitely wasn't [ __ ]
wasn't cheap
you did that put my head down and got to
it
that's a bar right there got to it man
uh all right so the project's out
what else is coming from you
um
tour
uh merch i'm about to get into my merch
[ __ ] like a [ __ ] bro i ain't
never done no real like yeah you gotta
bro that's just a whole [ __ ] revenue
stream drop once drop gear once a month
yeah something to really get locked in
with that uh i got some dope ass
designers
drop a bong bruh like i said we finna
get into all that bro like and
the thing is like i i got ben doing like
little [ __ ] like i used to go to [ __ ]
meetings all the time with the roar
glass company
yeah yeah and they we was like trying to
do something but i never really had the
platform and the [ __ ] to do it now you
do yeah so like i'm about to really get
touched basically because you're the
only rapper pushing bong culture man
yeah everybody else is on backwards i
[ __ ] hate backwoods yeah i [ __ ]
ate all that [ __ ] bro backwards to me is
like swisher i smoke swishers i'm not
mad at a blunt
i think we talked about it because the
the blunt life is still very uh shout
out to swisher man alive partnership
bro i love blunts
i do the blunt or just the papers the
pre-roll the cone stuff your weed in
because i'm not good at rolling so it's
got to be kind of done for me yeah well
[ __ ] i smoke swishers the bong life and
swishers
because they cut that check
shout out to them hey swisher sponsor
the [ __ ] podcast
table full of [ __ ]
swishers swisher game yeah but like uh
yeah a lot a lot of good [ __ ] um
just uh i want to actually want to just
drop a lot more music but i do want to
take time to myself
like because i ain't never did that bro
go on vacation man yeah i want to do
something like go to hawaii just me and
my little dude or something you feel me
myself
take him to hawaii and get your [ __ ]
driver's license
you're a [ __ ] adult bro
and i'm gonna give my
yeah there's no excuse no laptop told me
to get my id just get something yeah
i got him you were born in 1994
you're no listen bro you're knocking on
30. but uh the the life i live i can't i
don't know what i can't explain it but
i'm gonna get it though i'm gonna figure
it out i'm gonna get my driver's license
shout out to the bullet kid yeah you
gotta get that i'm gonna do it for you
bro there's just certain [ __ ] in life
you gotta get cause what are you 28
yeah you're 28 bro it's time
it's time man yeah that's our job bro um
bro
bro there's outside there's my dmv in
glendale it's full of armenians i'm sure
shout out to the armenian homie my guy
esta here you just make an appointment
online you pull up you handle it you go
home and you you're you know what's
crazy i don't think i'm gonna pass the
test
you probably won't that's the thing yeah
that's what i'm saying i don't think i'm
a pastor you gotta study bro that's the
thing both see you it's now we've gotten
to the root of the problem yeah you
don't wanna study yeah
like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] i know what i'm
doing
yeah but you gotta you gotta pass the
test oh listen these [ __ ] could
barely drive bro the people who got like
this can't drive bro so
yeah but you gotta get a lot you drive
with two feet for real how about imma
get a driver [ __ ] a driver's license i
mean that's a good i mean but that's
also probably an unnecessary expense at
this point for sure you know how much
money that's been over what the [ __ ] oh
my god your license
but i'm not gonna
but stop driving with two feet because
you're not 12. [ __ ] that's like the
go-kart [ __ ] yeah this isn't ridge racer
at the arcade bruh bro listen i'ma get
it together one day yeah don't double
foot the [ __ ] guy you gotta just one
foot left to right get a [ __ ] tesla
it'll drive itself you just got to make
sure it don't crash i i i be driving
tesla's all the time and [ __ ] up the
brakes
because i you know
it really like stops the car when you
got chills you break it but when you got
your feet on both pedals at once oh my
god yeah you really hey shout out to my
guy ruchi man he got the driving habits
of a 14 year old
i'm still man i'm doing it man he's
doing it he's got new music coming the
new project is out tour all type of good
[ __ ] man child bullet kid gang gang
there it is